Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the YAWHG. Now the YAWHG is
a kind of choose your own adventure
style game where anything is possible.
I need to pick two characters and I'm
gonna take them with me on an adventure
through whatever the hell the YAWHG is
because that's as far as I know SOO
I am gonna piiick
[singing starts in background] ohh
I'm gonna pick
oh that guy with the beard!
The mutton chops on that guy ooh and I'm gonna take red
lady got it I got a team i'm good to go
I'm already ready you don't need to
serenade me anymore
the YAWHG will be here in six weeks and
no one expects it
not a one of us we just keep on living
our lives week by week unaware okay so
is the YAWHG a monstrous entity that's
going to consume all of life as we know it
ooo whaaat ooh ooo physique finesse mind
charm magic and wealth
I don't know I think this guy needs to
spend his time in the tavern...bartending!
he seems like oh! you spend the week
serving drinks at the tavern you earn
one wealth in tips and gain two charm
one day a bard pulls out his lute
in the bar and starts playing a tune
unfortunately his singing is horrible and
is ruining the tavern's atmosphere
well okay
you decide to do something about it
oh so this is where it's like a "choose your own
adventure" type deal
Amy told me about this one and was really
excited about it. So, I could convince
him to leave but I could challenge
him to a lute duel because apparently I -
what are the odds I'm gonna be any worse?
come on bring it on
you borrow the bar
owners lute and challenge the bard to a
musical duel
you only just started
playing the lute when you realize that
you're even worse than the baaar-,...
aww c'mon!
the bard easily outplays you
and motions for you to lay down your flute
so it's like a passive aggressive like hey c'mon now
I may not be a professional but you need to
just get the fuck out of here because
this is horrible
you can tell there are a couple of
people snickering at you right now
embarrassing you lose one ch-
well...
well damn it! I'm off to a great
start here
alright so i guess lady red she seems
like she belongs in the palace
Oh, attend the ball! Ah you spend a week
attending fancy gatherings
oh what a burdensome week oh how will I
get through it? You gain two charm and
one finesse one day you decide to lean up
against the wall just to take a break
it rotates as you apply pressure and you
stumble down a set of stairs you enter
a large dusty room filled with barrels
You've found the King's famous wine cellar host a
secret party OH what better way
I'm sure the king will forgive me all
your friends show up and begin the
drinking when you come to you find
yourself in a home you don't recognize
in only your underwear your clothes
are nowhere to be found and you seem to be
the only one home
what happened?! ah, sounds like a fun
time they say the last time it came the
YAWHG devoured house whole. stole lives tore
families and family members apart but
that was so very long ago
okay I'm a little bit more worried about
this YAWHG than I previously was were
alright so the other thing that this guy
does is that he goes down Lumberjacks in the woods
all by hims- aw hell yea he chops wood
spend the week cutting down trees for the village
you gain two physique and earn yourself one wealth
one day during your forest
excursions you stumble upon a swarm
of rats at first you jump backwards in shock
but then you start hearing them
conversing with one another they call
you over
excuse me sir one of them says in a
high-pitched voice do you think you
might be able to help us out with
something you see we are just trying to
elect a new leader but it seems our
votes are completely tied
we're trying to decide between seedpaws
the vengeful and blighttooth
the wise
seedpaws steps forward if you vote for me
the rats will have a powerful leader one
that isn't afraid to take our fight to
the enemy proclaims Seedpaw. Blighttooth
steps up if you vote for me good sir
i will lead these rats to an age of
enlightenment says Blighttooth
which rat do you choose?
well I don't know maybe it's not about
what I do but maybe if i take it from my
favorite movie ratatouille i'm gonna
assume that whenever talking rats
decided to show themselves to me that
they probably shouldn't be vindictive
and vengeful because that would probably
lead to a lot of pain around the world
so I'm gonna go with Blighttooth. Half the rats roar
with tiny applause *markimoo giggles* I just thought of-
I thought of that mouse,
that howling mouse. *laughs* from that
don't laugh video I did, oh geez, all right, anyway
"Seedpaw bows his head and walks back
into the mass of rats. Blighttooth
climbs on your shoulder and
whispers ancient secrets in your ear."
that's thanks, thank you Blighttooth
"You gain one mind and one magic!" Well that
better than last time to go to the
garden have a good time meditating spend
the weekend deep meditation- boy, boy, this lady
has a rough time going through this week
preparing for the YAWGH "You gain one
magic and two mind. One day on your way
home from the park you come across the
golden ring in the grass, Wear the ring"
it might be cha- enchanted or cursed.
I'm gonna go with wearing it. "Upon placing
the ring on your finger orange markings
around the- *Mark malfunctions*
The marking unravel themselves from the ring and swirl
in front of you, they form into what appears to be a
fully armored ghost radiating a beautiful
orange light the ghost turns to you
and nods before walking away.
The ring looks good on you!"
Hey! All right then, I should mention that
this is all randomly generated so these
outcomes probably are sporadic or maybe
it's not all randomly generated but you
know what i mean. "It was on us in a
heartbeat- or so the stories go.
The earth shook, the air went still."
Ok then, time fight in the arena!
I'm gonna fight, not compete, or bet.
" You spend the week fighting brutes in the arena.
You gain into two Physique and one Finesse.
While wandering around the halls between matches,
You spot your former lover Kelly.
An awkward exchange happens, in which you
want to know how they're doing without
seeming to care too much.
After a few minutes, Jean, one of the most
popular fighters in the arena,
butts into the conversation.
'Hey Kelly, sorry to interrupt ya babe, but we've
gotta leave right now if we want to make
your mother's in time.'" Ya know, to uuuh- not bang
cause that'd be weird in front of your mom (yes it would)
"You say an awkward goodbye as they walk off
holding hands.
How do you feel?" I feel happy, I'm happy for her.
Hope her house burns down, but I'm happy.
"You feel It's good that both of you have moved on.
This encounter, despite its awkwardness, was refreshing.
You gain one Charm." Hell yeah.
Oh yeah, I do.
Hell yeah, I do. All right time to go to
the tavern and DRIIINK! "You spend the
entire week getting wasted. You gain two Charm and
one Physique. There very first day of
the week, when you walk through the
tavern doors, everyone cheers. Apparently
during your last drunken outing, you were
a party animal while you were blacked out.
yeah oh yeah how I was legend spread of
your party hard spirit game future
oh yeah man the lady can do no wrong and
then the world with howling fury chaos
the sound of all we knew being pulled in
half
well that's dark and ominous alright
I'm it's man time to go to the slums and
fight crime you spend a week outsmarting
and feeding up criminals Gain one mind
one physique one from this hell yeah
one night a small child approach you
with his hand cupped out stretched out towards you.
It's a trap beat him up
you don't say anything but looks up at
you with wide eyes waiting expectedly
punch the shit out of them
and fine I'll do it
you taught them a sack of coins you lose
one well He thanks you and walked away
the next night you recognize him on the
street spot a eating what looks like a
fresh loaf of bread he sees you and
smiles you feel good about yourself
Oh. My muscles have grown. I can't believe it. that role you come to use it
and 14 next one mind one charm
wow I'm doing good whatever these things
mean really i'm doing good
alright we're going to be alchemy tower
that's let's brew a potion and maybe
some booze along with it
it's been a week experimenting with
different potion brooze you get into
magical mind when they swarm of rats
infests building. They are biting
everything in the way everyone else in
the building please immediately so you
What do we do? Blast them with magic.
with is its litter possède pauses seed
pawn his gang unruly after losing the
election- I'mma blast them. If you wave your
hands and produce bouquet
of flowers. That wasn't the spell you
meant to cast. The rats spot your attempt to
exterminate them to get fighting you
horribly- OW my physique managed to escape
but now there are rats all over the
tower
well that didn't go so well things were
going well but oh well when it arrives
this time how will be fair we want more
rebuild move on be strong
who have we forgotten I don't know I
don't know I just don't know
ok so they've got the palace to do
administrative work if that's the kind
of guy he is
you spend a week doing paperwork to pay
to welcome Game one mind one day the
court jester approaches you would you
like to learn to juggle ya excited me
please you haven't taken our first of
all calm baby he doesn't know how to
juggle maybe there's a trap sure why not
spend the day with a gesture practicing
your juggling technique you improve
dramatically you gain susan s another to
the head you happily favors after
services you lose one well when I was
not very girl things out of the hospital
tend to pieces
you spend the week diagnosing and
tending to the sick you get into mine
and then one well one day you hear em IQ
strong and check out into the hospital
soon afterwards the glowing blue ghost
floats down from the ceiling seems to be
wondering how the agency howling out
horrible noise he doesn't have to
realize that you freaking everyone ho
and it threw up in my mouth a little bit
because it was so spooky decide to do
something about it
talk calmly to the ghost you approach
the spirit and try to explain how to her
the effect she is having on the sick she
seems to understand what you're telling
her and apologizes for bothering
everybody she walks through a wall and
it's never seen from again a doctor
tosses you a sack of coins as a way of
saying thanks. You gain 2 wealth
Hey! The YAWHG.  it's almost here
almost almost
ooH! it's getting spoopy up in here
alright man you gotta go let's go for a hunt
hot let's go for a good old hunt you
spend the week hunting defenseless
creatures like the good person I am
you gain finesse and sell the pelts
for one wealth. one day you come across a
group of people in the woods from the
expression on their faces they appear to
be lost help them don't rob them
you confront the group and try to help them
find their way back into town. with ease
you need everyone back to town extremely
grateful the group gives you a small
token of appreciation. you gain two wealth
Wow for a guy that's been giving away his
wealth left and right he, he certainly
has a lot of wealth
alright lady, time to go
it's the end of the world so what do you
do? get druuuunk!! hell yeeaaaah
one day an impromptu drinking contest
is held
oh that sounds  like my kind of thing you
down pint after pint, drinking as if your
life depends on it.
you end up blacking out again when you
come to you find yourself at home you
don't recognize. in only your underwear
your clothes are nowhere to be found
you seem to be the only one home what
happened Oh another good time oo shit
the storm arrives in the night the morning
and still rages two three full days the
tempest puts us through a grinder drowns
us crushes us ruins us but then it
ends we see the graveyard our home has
become our home does anything yet
live is it
are we past saving
oh shit whoa choose the role i don't even
know what that means what does that mean i don't
know i don't know but i think this guy
is going to be the smelter hell yeah you
volunteer to smell your now-useless
coins in the building materials
ok with a modest amount of riches you
have you managed to provide a
significant amount of income you melt it
all down with the smiths take it and work
on various tools and building materials
it helps to survive effort a lot you
lose three wealth
alright then oh she's got a lot of charm
she should be the leader
I vote for uh government that lets
everyone party and black out as much as
they want to without getting judged for
their actions no such thing as past mistakes
only the future! vote for me
you take it upon yourselves to be the leader of the
survivors you expertly delegated
prioritize tasks give motivating
speeches act as an effective mediator
and disputes that helps the rebuilding
effort significantly I know I know
and so we set about our tasks once more
living our lives this time in a way we
might have never expected or wanted
but in the end it was a struggle but a
struggle we never abandoned though our
home had been stripped part we did not
let it languish whether we succeed or
fail we did our best
who knows if the Yawhg will visit us again
who knows if we will ever be can ever be
ready for it. that was cool it was cool it was
really cool
we rebuilt we did it through drinking
and partying
we're good with the old tavern owner
dying in the Yawhg you decide to take on
the task before long the taverns busier
than ever filled with good music games
and friends
your taverns doing so great that every other
tavern in the area is closed down you
start to change the taverns throughout
the city to fill the demand each new
tavern you make and open makes it more
difficult to manage them all. you began
acting policies that make it easier for
you to keep track of how many taverns
are being run the taverns all start to
become bland and uninteresting places to
be
but since you have a monopoly you're still making
ridiculous amount of money that's...that's
boring. the Yawhg changed you probably for the
better but the town being refilled you
eventually decide to retake your role as
a doctor and hospital there you make
friends with another doctor the two of
you do everything together youre
inseparable
eventually you decide to get an
apartment and live with each other then
your friend gets married
everything changes the spouse has to
move away to a new town and your
friend follows you try to keep in touch by
mail but the letters start to come less and
less frequently you tried to fraternize
with the other doctors while they're all
nice people nothing can compare that's
sad. but thats sad! well i'm sad now I was
happy about the rebuilding the both of
those were kind of sad! the rebuilding
was optimistic but the people that were
doing it
led sad lives on man how is
crazy
that was like a short 15-minute
experience that I really loved I felt
attached to those people I felt a part of
that how did i do that in 15 minutes
I love that and I bet i'm willing to bet
every playthroughs going to be a little
bit different I mean sure you can play
to the point where you get every single
possibility but i bet every playthroughs
going to be different so I'm gonna leave
this one the way it is
I'm gonna let my playthrough be what it
is but this game is cool like
legitimately cool just kind of all the
possibilities that could happen and also
seeing that how the decisions kind of
echo through because she lived life
party and doesn't remember stuff and
then she ends up being forgotten and the
guy i don't know i only went to bartend
one that was the first thing and so he
went back again i guess and made a lot
of money but money wasn't what it was
all about anyway
and became boring because of it
its cool though and i love the music so either way
I'll end this here i'll stop blabbering
about my feelings about this and let me
know what you guys think down the
comments below I really want to hear your
opinions about this if you played this
before how different how many ways are
there to go about this so anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you... in the next video
bye bye!